hey I'm Peter Rubin & I'm Kelly Rubin
this is Crosby this is split screen
because we know there's more than one
side to every story in every movie every
game every TV show speaking of which
there's there's always more than one
side to every madman that's right and we
are entering the last half of the last
season what we've actually entered it
it's already happening yes I know the
roller coaster has begun but I'm sad and
happy at the same time I I don't want to
see it end but I just want to know how
it ends yeah all at the same time and I
feel like the writers know that because
the season premiere was titled severance
yeah it's time to let go it is and while
the title severance referred to chem
actually getting fired something that is
really sad to me because I had in my
professional career in advertising a
moment where I had to say am I going to
pursue my creative dreams or am I gonna
stick in this job and do one last game
one last price one last thing and Ken
decided and made his choice hmm
primarily based on his fight which is
noble because it was fight for Pete
Campbell yes so that's deserving but
still I can imagine how frustrating it
is yes it hurt me yeah that was like the
literal interpretation of the episode
title and on the more figurative side we
have Don Draper's and ability to let go
of just about any woman in his life yes
and also his perhaps severance with
reality and also his possibly weakening
grip on reality which is something that
we've seen more and more in the later
seasons engines and nightmares and now
in the season premiere he was convinced
that he knew this waitress and I had a
dream about his ex-lover Rachel who then
died and so that'll make him let go it
won't you think it would make him live
out of a well no as a man who's still
wearing grill cream in the 70s it's true
though he is the only man to not have a
mustache in 1978
but those are some great must have those
are some fantastic massage as you know
who's never gonna have a mustache ah no
Joan and Peggy also true who had a great
scene a great episode and are seeming
super mad which is always really
pleasing to me yeah they have every
reason to be mad right now yeah like
every move they make is somehow propped
it is and as much progress as Joan has
made throughout the years and being
taken seriously and becoming a partner
she still had that horrible meeting with
the clowns at the parent company break
one glass ceiling and then there's
another glass ceiling and just keep
going and going to have to see what's
gonna happen with Jones head hitting all
of these glass ceiling she's gonna split
one of those screams you see what I did
there it's the name of our show it's
grant Swift screened out that yeah I
have another one next week so while we
won't be talking about men then we will
hopefully see you there bye